new video from Texas DPS shows another
bust of the Border illegal immigrants
seen hiding under hay bales in the back
of a truck this as we learn people are
creating phony families to enter so what
can be done to stop the surge former DHS
acting deputy secretary Ken cuccinelli
joins us now Ken thanks for being here
this morning so we're seeing especially
with Brazilians for some reason we're
seeing an uptick in this thousands of
Brazilian children basically being
rented to create phony families so maybe
the mom comes with the with the child
and then a man pays her off to rent her
child so they look like they're a family
because that way they can stay here I
mean why do we still have laws that
encourage this kind of it's clearly
dangerous for the child
uh it is dangerous for the child I mean
we've had statistics for years that not
just the child women in particular as
well they're they're molested or
assaulted 30 of them on the way up in
this journey
um and look who's running the pipeline
it's cartels and coyotes and and gangs
um and they're making more money
arguably off the human trafficking
coming across our border now than they
are with drug trafficking so they will
play any game they can and this is
dangerous for the children and the only
you're not going to stop it until
there's an announced intent that anyone
believes to stop the flow across the
border but the president has an open
borders policy I mean they still show up
with Joe Biden for president t-shirts
and that is that is step one yeah so I I
still can't wait a long way from that no
I know but I I you know it's so cruel to
children it's so outrageous for a
government to be complicit in the child
sex trade and all the things that are
happening because of this policy I'm
just price they haven't been held more
to account for that you know other than
this network it's just not happening I
want to move to another topic and that
is that new CBP data reveals at 69
are on the FBI's Tara watch list have
been caught 69 terrorists that's set to
break the record already we're on Pace
to break the record from last year of
almost 100 98 I believe was the number
what do you make of this especially as
we know that Isis is reconstituting we
just thwarted an ISIS attack just this
week on our own soil
so first of all we'll all ask the big
question how many didn't we catch right
and again with this open borders policy
um the the goal for these kinds of
people crossing the border is to avoid
the border patrol and yet 69 were caught
and remember the border patrol as we
heard testimony from the from the chief
this week is overwhelmed they have not
secured the Border contrary to
majorcus's constant refrain but the
people actually responsible for it
telling the truth to Congress that the
border is not secure this is going to
have consequences for years into the
future and I would note that even
Democrat voters haven't supported Joe
Biden's open borders policy literally
for two years almost since its
implementation and so this is not a
mainstream even Democrat
policy that they're implementing this is
a radical left-wing race our borders
power policy and I hope that the now
bare majority of Republicans in the
house are able to make a dent in it
because as you note
our security is at risk this is the kind
of record you don't want to set produced
that one yesterday the second number one
seed ever lose to a 16. those are the
kinds of Records you don't want to set
in the security Arena it's the new
record for terrorists crossing the
border and Joe Biden holds the record
yeah I think all that Congress can do
can is just shine a light on it um
there's not really not much they can do
to stop this or else they would have
unfortunately I think probably the only
thing that will cause a rethinking on
the part of the Democrats will be a
terrorist attack and we certainly have
all the makings for that to happen with
these record numbers of terrorists
coming across our border Ken thanks for
joining us this morning
good to be with you okay I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis